fourth of july
yes it's our movie can
i don't want to do the film hey tell us
about it whatever but like can you can
you
tell us about it
you know i i want people to know about i
want people to go out and support it and
they can buy it now that's another thing
right it's going to be when is this on
ideally we put it out tomorrow okay so
then saturday so it's coming up okay
it's drops on my website perfect yes
louis ck.com that's right and can you
give us a breakdown of the story how
this even
came to be why should people go see this
it's like it's a it's a family movie
it's it got it like well it's about a
family it's about a family it's not a
family movie it's not for a family yeah
we say
yes [ __ ] [ __ ]
a
lot
[Laughter]
yes
and what is the story
uh the story is about um it's about a
guy uh
who um
i'm much better with just zingers you
know okay so it's about a guy
it's about a guy who's uh new york um
young fella
uh
and he's anxious
living in a river of anxiety just con
never stops coming and he's just is this
okay is this all right
uh no i shouldn't it's just living that
way all the time but he's living that
way yeah he's kind of on a cruise
control of anxious uh you know uh um
living yes and sober he has he's sober
uh he's you know working at it he's an
aaa he's got a sponsor who he's not
doing a great spot he's late to his
sponsor meeting and it's that's also a
little tough for him
and he's married and he has a nice easy
relationship with this woman that he
just that's his light that's his nice
that's where he's confident and happy
when he's with her uh but the rest of
his life is kind of a mess and he's also
a jazz pianist and he succeeds there he
feels good when he's playing jazz piano
um
and uh he goes to therapy and i'm his
therapist and um he
so anyway he um
he just he's he asked his wife when he
sees i mean i'll tell the main
scene because i think it's the turning
point
he sees his wife texting with her friend
while she's in the bathroom but he sees
it on her on her computer screen and he
and he sees he's about to see something
and he closes it but it makes him
anxious and he asks his wife he goes i'm
just
do you say something to your friends
about me that i just i don't is there
something that you don't that and she
just says i am not fulfilled because we
don't have a kid
that's what i really wanted we never did
it and so i'm not
happy and he just he's the last thing he
expected was it was something very real
not about him and his quirks but
um your wife your wife the light of your
life is not okay yeah
and he says what but why did you just
stop talking about having a kid she says
yeah because yes and he sort of gleans
from me you don't really you don't think
i could be a dad
and it's a horrible realization to him
and he comes to his therapist and he
says what do i do
and i kind of go well yeah you know it's
okay
and he realizes his therapist and his
wife everyone gave up on him ever
stepping up and being a father being a
man and that life is passing him by
and so he what he keys on is that his
parent he has this terrible
fear and anxiety about his parents that
they that they showed him no love that
he doesn't know how to be loved so he's
gonna go
to back home
to maine where his parents are from
boston and they go to maine every summer
and he's going to confront them he's
going to confront all this [ __ ] and he's
going to get it out of himself so he
goes there and it's it's just his family
is just this melee of just [ __ ]
boston ego id people that just say
whatever they want they drink like crazy
and they're offended that he doesn't
drink
because he's sober
and he's trying to find a moment where
he can claim his manhood there and so
that's really what it's about it's about
him going home and trying to do
the demons yeah and then those people
are you know and nick apollo nails this
character as his uncle tony v these two
guys are like the twin towers of like
[ __ ] boston hate yeah and uh and but
love too yeah they're mad at him for
being sober because they love him and
they miss when he was a loser like they
are yeah yeah which is what it is to
grow up in boston really and
and so it's that's him trying to deal
with that and it's all just flailing and
[ __ ] up and uh and hijinks ensues
it's funny and it's sad and it's did
this happen to you
because you're married yeah this sounds
very autobiographical it's all very real
therapists basically it's all very real
there's a lot of stuff taken a lot of
actual dialogue from my real life and
then we heightened the family of course
and then the mother in the movie is more
like sociopathic louis kind of created
the mother cat yeah the mother was sort
of like women in boston that i grew up
around that fascinated me these powerful
women yeah that say things in lyrical
they use big words sometimes like what
the one i pointed out when we were
looking at it yesterday that she says by
by the grace of god you're in this
family and by my wrath you'll be out you
know that's how boston women talk
so that mother character was this
opportunity to create these and that the
characters like the mother is a great
actress she's we
if you populate a movie with the
comedians let them sharp shoot but then
you have actors that can really drive at
home yeah and that was and robert kelly
is he's obviously he's both yeah because
robert's a great comic but he's actually
a virtuoso actor yeah he could do
anything yeah so he plays his sponsee
it's really it's a good movie it is good
damn good i'm damn proud of it and it's
feels
and it's not from me it's the thing i
loved about it was i was sort of in
service of joe
he really wanted to make a movie i
didn't have a story in me at the time
and so we had we mixed some ideas that
we both had but it was really his story
um so i got to just direct and get get
his vision up i feel bad that i didn't
see it before you guys came yeah you
[ __ ] up mark saw it yeah he went to
the theater did you like it i did i
thought it was wonderful i saw it on the
i
yeah village cinemas and uh we premiered
at the beacon there was like two
thousand people yeah
so joe's telling me that and i think
that's the craziest thing like
seeing a movie with two thousand people
seeing an action movie when there's a
couple hundred people in a movie theater
it feels great to see comedy i remember
seeing the first hangover at a sold-out
theater and then laughing with other
people in it great feeling
it's awesome it's nice
well that's what we discovered with this
we got a very small distributor to we
just went out
to each place and first we did these big
premieres where we got to be there and
watch people laugh but then the great
thing was hearing because what we would
do we we're sort of in the middle so
like amc theaters gave us like 72 cities
in one night seven o'clock on a
wednesday all over and then it's done
but we packed all of those yeah
screenings and then added shows
and we kept getting reports and he got a
lot of feedback on instagram people
saying that they were there that they
loved that they were there and they all
laughed together and people would
applaud at the end this is what's great
about film and people keep saying like
well the movie theaters are dying well
if you give them a little blood it all
comes back because that experience
that's right is unmatched yeah we were
supposed to do like one week some but we
were we're there we just kept holding
over the lemley in l.a kept getting held
over
kept getting held over here and then
these one-night screenings kept moving
around to different cities and packing
the places and joe said that they were
blown away by the amount of money it
made and i won't say that the number
because i know how sensitive you are
with that but it was like multiple times
it did but it's not a lot of money but
for for theaters
we did way better than we expected and
this is with really we didn't really
advertise very much no promo your email
list the email list and then his and his
social media stuff and a few podcasts
and uh but it was word of mouth the
thing that was crazy was watching the
theaters where it was in consecutive
nights it would increase every night
yeah every night and uh we realized that
we hit on something for four people that
they're into the guy who distributed is
a very old school guy he said he was
like because it's the non-algorithmic
movie
it doesn't have a thing like a person's
name or an issue it's just a movie about
failing people yeah and you can work
this algorithm is supposed to be so
genius but it is limited because it only
knows what it knows it doesn't know
anything outside of itself it doesn't
have the ability to include something
like well no one thought that was going
to work yeah so
and it's all an experiment for me i'd
never done a theatrical release
independently
and this is the first time i've put a
movie on my website and it's the first
time we've done those two both things it
was theatrical first so i don't know how
it's going to do was it cool to see
laughs oh sorry go yeah probably similar
question what's it like watching your
movie crush versus crushing as a
stand-up it was weird because we found
first of all it's about my life so it's
drama to me and the whole time we were
writing louie was like we're writing a
comedy and i'm like no we're writing a
drama it's a classic thing it reminds me
of the mel brooks story about you ever
see they ask them between comedy and
drama
and he says
drama is i get a paper cut on my thumb
and i'm i'm bleeding and i get a
band-aid and i call my wife and i keep
pouring peroxide on it and i'm checking
on it that's drama comedy is you're
walking down the street and you fall in
a hole and die yeah
what do i care about
so that's how i felt i was like this is
a drama and it's all very dramatic and
we cut out a lot of jokes and then we
played it at the theater at the beacon
and there was huge laughs in places
thousands of people that's another thing
like yeah you don't watch movies in
front of thousands not usually well and
the beacon theater was a movie theater
it was open as a movie theater it was a
movie theater all the way till the 70s
from like the 20s to the 70s so that's
how people used to watch movies together
and the rich people down there the poor
people up here yeah and everybody
watched together that's how they watch
stand up yeah that's right
my theater got a laugh before the movie
even started like just from the text
that comes up on screen i want to say
this but there's just a text on it that
comes on like in the very intro you got
a big laugh yeah i think that's cool
because sometimes those moments like uh
it and it's an edit really it's like an
editor's choice to like put a reaction
here gets this big explosive laugh that
you would never [ __ ] think because
you're like painstakingly looking over
every line that you say and every
delivery of this and sometimes people
are just engaged by the character
sometimes the character just being
themself in the moment is what's going
to end that's right and i didn't know
what i had with joe i thought
i was prepared for needing to teach him
how to the basics of acting and how to
not just be waiting to deliver you're
funny yeah but to and he's the lead
character so he can't he can't be a
sniping comic just with moments that you
can cut around he had to carry the movie
yeah and so i had no idea how it would
be but i was dug in for i'm going to
have to you know because my thing is
it's not we're going to get it it's
going to be good but how long is it
going to take that's good so if you suck
my movie's not going to be bad yeah
you're just going to be here all day
yeah
yeah i'll use other people and i'll
figure out how i'm going to cut it that
i'm going to get around you you that you
suck how much does it but he but he i
just want to finish this so you please
please yeah why i said it he was an
automatic he was just he was an easy
automatic it was
it was such a first of all a huge relief
and it let me put attention on
everything else that was going on i'd
just be like yeah he's got it he's got
it he every every take a virtuoso if you
will he was there he was just there but
not just that he was playing himself
which isn't as easy as it sounds it's
harder it is i think in a sense but also
just the way he listened to folks it
made me comfortable knowing i can always
cut to him if nothing else is working
because he's really in it yeah and i
feel for him in the in every shot yeah
and he's funny i i wonder if it's easier
for comics to do
drama
because
when we're on stage a lot of times we're
being serious about these things they
just happen to be funny
yeah a good comic is a comic who's uh uh
believable who's really in it i saw that
yes they are better as dramatic actors
which and then being a comedic actor is
being serious about something that you
know is absolutely ridiculous like will
ferrell is he's playing a character but
the character believes everything the
character's not trying to be funny he's
not trying to say like a core uh quip or
whatever like that yeah so i think
sometimes you see
comics do these like dramatic roles
you're like how the [ __ ] they pull that
off and it's like well that's closer to
stand up and also probably convincing it
probably removes the i don't need lefts
where we always have that need like if
i'm not getting laughs i'm getting
insecure yeah i'm starting to whatever
overact or whatever yeah it's a drama
and i don't hear the key grips laughing
who cares they're not supposed to laugh
yeah all that weight is off me now we're
just in this thing and living in the
moment like we would on stage yes
yeah and and
my i'm like a straight man essentially
in the movie how annoying is that though
that was fun for me i mean because i
i've been there i've been to dark places
they're just trying to recreate these
dark things yeah it's easier to act i
mean that's like a famous quote from uh
peter um
sellers
peter salad said it's uh it's easy to
pretend to be serious you can't pretend
to be funny yes so it's a lot easier to
pretend to be
yeah to be in it upset yeah yeah yeah